en réalité on a le sentiment que le
gouvernement n'a toujours pas compris à
quoi servait l'assemblée nationale ils
n'ont pas compris parce que la majorité
que de présidentielle semblait nationale
est en partie disloqué dans quatre
groupes politiques
ils ont gagné d'une manière assez
extraordinaire mais il manque
l'expérience est en réalité le pouvoir
quel qu'il soit quand les deux
gouvernements du président la république
ont négligé l'assemblée nationale donc
ils négligent le parlement et maintenant
ils me font des commissions dès qu'ils
ont un problème il va le faire une
commission alors comme ils ont beaucoup
de problèmes et qu'ils ne savent pas
faire et créer des commissions à tous
les niveaux
[Musique]